this is a production of cornell
university
uh episode 8 of the cornell turf show
this year in 2022
our guest today is ben palmer he's the
field and grounds conor coordinator for
the western westin massachusetts this is
a cool position i was reading about
actually so we may talk about
uh the sort of progressiveness of your
of your position ben uh he is strolled
into the lion's den today frank with a
sign that says eat me those those uh
listening on the podcast ben has come
wearing a boston red sox hat so uh we we
uh hopefully we'll make it through our
fastest 30 minutes in turf today without
a without a fight going on here but uh
as always frank i'll let you kick things
off uh with our episode today uh don't
worry it's on today ben
it is on uh we you know
we know we had to let it rest this is my
uh long time college buddy dan
cunningham's
33rd opening day uh at yankee stadium so
he's been there a long time and you know
the ironic thing is he's a rhode
islander he's a probably grew up a red
sox fan the poor guy so i'm completely
surrounded so it is on today ben we are
looking forward to it it is everything
uh we want to start the season get us
all excited to get going um and but
before we do that
carl what do you got for us today for
the staff
yeah so i was looking around at um
you know early season spring use is is
underway on on certain athletic fields
and and we're gonna see because there's
no growth here early in the season we're
gonna see things getting ripped up
notably these these things like goal
mouths if
um if you can't get some seed down or if
it's if it's slow to grow out of it
we're going to end up sating these
things at one point or another during
the year and i was interested in okay
what are some of the ways that they
prepare the sod that will best translate
when you lay that side uh and this is
actually work from evan machetti who we
had uh actually a couple weeks ago on
the on the show he looked at nitrogen
rates of producing sod
the mowing height of that side looked at
a couple other things like top dressing
and the biggest factor he found that
translated to that side rooting very
well
was the nitrogen rate
and actually the lower nitrogen rates he
found the three pounds of them per year
did better produced forty percent more
divot resistance
than sod that was managed with four
pounds of nitrogen per year
and so their theory theory was the plant
is prioritizing when it gets a lot of
nitrogen grown as sod it's prioritizing
leaf tissue growth and not that stolen
in root growth which is what we need for
that high divot resistance
so things to think about if you're
producing your own sod on the side if
you've got a little nursery
you maybe don't want to juice it quite
as much before it's going to get laid on
that field or maybe even working with
their sod producer and trying to find a
a nitrogen rate that's going to
translate well once that side is laid on
the field
it's very interesting carl because i'm
going to actually talk a little bit
about some things i saw out when i was
at the field day in oregon state around
the timing of the application right here
you see a
a preference for the fall
uh nitrogen load which you know
historically we've always said yeah this
is good for root growth because uh shoe
growth isn't favored at that time but at
the same time like last week at the
ground session we talked a lot with carl
about you know not going too much too
late right because of the potential
leaching so there's a nuance to the
timing of this we'll talk about it as as
as we keep going let me uh get to the
weather um and again uh
we've had adequate moisture the funny
thing you're going to see about what i'm
going to say we've had adequate moisture
we're expecting more moisture
right the 60 day 10 today outlook looks
like you know we got a really good
chance for getting more moisture but
there are still parts of the northeast
that this normal or slightly above
normal rainfall is not compensating for
the really dry conditions so you know
it's hard to remember this or think
about this when you know you see the
rains falling especially in the new york
metropolitan area where i know you know
specifically that the soils are fairly
soggy still and looking like they're
getting soggy or longer but it re you
know remember how we look at dry
conditions this is a cumulative measure
of groundwater and stream flow
and prehistoric precipitation versus
normal precipitation so in general we
would say it wasn't you know many people
would say it wasn't that wet of a winter
and this may be the lingering effects
and certainly the northern part of new
england you know where the five people
live in up northern new hampshire
vermont and maine uh it's getting pretty
dry
up in the woods up there
so the temperature departure it has been
on the warm side as well as wet uh or
recently i'm sorry has been on the cool
side the cool side it's been hitting the
pause button for the last couple of
weeks overall we've been warmer than
normal but in the recent weeks pretty
typically what we see with the way
springs are going these days is is that
we get going and then we hit pause so
right now it looks like we're in a pause
but looks like that's about to break art
d guytano uh our climate guy says we're
about to get very ridgy
right we're gonna get this warm air
coming up from the gulf region probably
by the middle of the week uh as as we
move forward so growing degree day wise
uh last week uh up until the sixth you
can see uh we're a little bit slightly
behind
through much of the northeast and again
until maybe the middle to the end of
next week you're still not going to be
accumulating more than the low teens so
things are going to warm up but you're
not going to see enormous uh progress uh
during the year oh wait i think i got
one more thing before i get to bed uh
two inch soil temperature
a few weeks ago it was 50 something
degrees now we're barely into the low
50s maybe starting to creep into the 50s
now ben is in a place uh where the soils
may be a little bit warmer and the
reason this is on here carl is because
of the meat thermometer right we are
going to start a company around using
meat thermometers in turf and this is a
tweet that ben gave us a few weeks ago
where he was tracking things talking
about goose poop
and when we look at temperature right
here's where it's been the last few
weeks and the growth potential we're
going to get there
the next few weeks we're going to see a
slight increase as we move to the upper
50s you see it go from 20 growth
potential to all of a sudden 60 growth
potential right so how much are we going
to get going and of course i always like
to think about not football necessarily
in the spring but are we open these
things fields up safe or do you have a
good network of information and
resources that you can get information
like our sports turf stuff
but remembering simple things like
generally we don't always promote it but
lower cut grass tends to warm a little
bit quicker right it brings that heat
into the soil
now here's the thing about fertility
carl and ben that i noticed and i don't
know how much tall fescue you have but i
was out in oregon in february uh late
late february march and they're looking
at uh a shift now in species to more
tall fescue now typically rye grass has
been good fine fescue does well out
there for the low input shady areas but
their summers are getting drier and
warmer consistently which is starting to
favor tall fescue uh in a different way
now one of the things they're saying
carl it's the same thing you said look
at the the color just the color of green
you get
by the same amount of n applied at
different times looking at what they
look like at this time of year and you
can see those later end rates what are
they about 0.6 pounds per app that's a
good app uh you get it on before
mid-october even in new england you
still feel pretty good about it uh and
then you get this really nice spring
green up now nothing does it is good
really as covers and we've been talking
about this like crazy in the golf
business but again ben i caught you
tweeting right time to start overseeing
right you see the bare soil right we've
done a lot of this i've talked about it
in the past chuck and seed even on
crappy looking fields gives you that
little bit of peach fuzz right on top
there sometimes it can translate if you
do it intensely to crab grass control
and we got weeks till we're talking
about anything with regard to crabgrass
control right now right so
uh here you are and
from an educational perspective big
shout out to the new england guys and i
think i know almost everybody in that
picture
uh with you in one way shape or form
especially the guy on the right we were
chatting retirement last time i just saw
it but i also want to shout out to a
fund i know you've promoted yourself i
didn't know are you congrats
uh well my wife did a graduate work at
uconn so i have a i have a uh
close affinity to the uh the yukon group
and i'll tell you
this guy is going to win the award
someday
for one of the most unsung guys in turf
grass science who probably contributed
more than a lot of people that are
fellows of our scientific association
because he just went about his business
did a lot of teaching in fact i think
was as busy after he retired uh as he
was before he retired okay ben a couple
of hacks hear you applying gypsum
to some of your salt affected sites and
again carl this is so great you can see
what i love here is what we've seen on
this campus
where you get the splashing
and the running of the water up in here
right you can see that it breaks
dormancy and then the
splashy cold water
gets on it right and so here's ben
making a uh
uh gypsum application one of the few
uses i think for gypsum
in our climate it really the only as far
as i can tell and here we are uh
re-seeding now i want to ask you this
it's a good place to start here's a
picture of one of our baseball fields in
glens falls new york just the other day
made it into the newspaper
why do you use tetraploid rye grass
let's start there that was a pretty cool
tweet why do you like that particular
rye grass is it cheap
uh yeah well it's cheap and
pam pam sherrod down at uh ohio state we
started to do some research uh she
posted some articles and whatnot trying
that they say
right this tetraploid rye grass will uh
germinate at lower temperatures uh this
is my second year using it uh
anecdotally i don't see a really any
difference right now
um but we're willing to try it right and
and i've always
been taught the seed doesn't do any good
in the bag right it does good on the
field
right so
so let's put it out so we had a little
bit of tetraploid ryegrass left over
from last year we put it out on some
spots that we just couldn't get some
recovery back last fall
and uh we'll put it out there
um
so yeah we're
proceeding right off the bat okay good
that's good so you like so so let's get
going here
let's first for for carl bringing this
up and i'm really glad he did let's talk
a little bit about the nature of your
position because one of the things i
think a lot of people don't realize you
know golf's having a lot of labor
trouble
your line of work needs more competent
grounds people maybe who come from the
golf course
and there's probably a lot more
opportunities than people always give uh
credit to so can you talk a little bit
about your path and actually your role a
little bit now yeah yeah so uh i
graduated from delaware valley
university uh with agronomy
environmental science background
uh it's started in sports never left
sports didn't go to the golf world no
matter what doug said exactly you had
doug lindy and
he might he you couldn't turn you into a
golf guy that's right and uh i was one
of the few
and uh yeah we're i started right out of
uh leaving doug i went and worked for
longer quicker club right in metro
boston learned how to take care of po
annual tennis courts and that was
interesting right you learned a thousand
ways to kill poland now we were trying
to keep it running
i was there for a few years and then
took a sports turf manager role out in
central massachusetts for a private
school i was there for six years and
then i've been here since uh
uh december
2015
as the first
basic sports field manager they had here
in this town we're 12 miles outside of
boston how many acres how many acres of
fields what kind of fields uh we manage
about 51 acres of turf and that's lawn
you know lawn municipal lawn school
lawns high-end sports fields pocket
parks
uh so yeah just around 51 acres
do you oversee the schools as well the
school sports fields ah various yes so
so schools probably take up about 80
percent of my time
and the schools have a lot of facilities
a lot of acreage uh synthetic fields you
can see the ones behind me i got one one
there
uh one
up there too
um you know so we're managing municipal
lawns uh
snow control in the winter right snow
and ice so we're always battling putting
down ice melt and then as you saw gypsum
going out trying to battle that
a lot you know lawn care uh shade tree
perennials perennial beds
um
you know sometimes agronomy is low on
the priority list
so let me start
with this job didn't exist till you
correct we've had the similar transition
here at cornell with a new golf and
sports director turf director of golf
and sports turf the golf course and the
sports fields and then we're going to
have a golf course superintendent so
those kinds of opportunities are are
really cool and the of the 51 acres
a certain amount of it is sports fields
how do you with some synthetic turf
available ben how do you decide in the
spring when to let them on the natural
surfaces
when they have when you have that
um
sort of synthetic surface available that
will help you when you know you got 20
growth potential yeah well and that's it
we use those early early in the spring
right we were probably give or take
about a week ahead of our schedule
normally this year um so you know
priority starts with our varsity school
sports and then works the way down the
youth
um we have great relationship with our
youth groups uh and they ask us almost
on a daily basis are fields available
our fields up and running or playable or
not um again those two synthetics take
the pressure off the natural grass
fields
um
we have enough we're we're great here we
have enough fields we can take one field
offline per season uh and i have a
rotating schedule
and that's well known to our youth
groups this is what our schedule's going
to be and what fields does that let you
sacrifice it sometimes ben it's like
listen okay it's crappy we need this
field it's safe it might be a little
wetter than i'd like but it's little
kids and i can put four fields and use
areas that don't get beat up can you be
creative like that with a swing for you
yeah so perfect example our soccer
complex we can put three 9v9 fields in
we put two in this year
uh one side of course close to the
parking lot close where everyone goes
that's site gets beat up a little bit
it's also shaded too so it doesn't get
sunlight uh we decided not to put a 9v9
field there to kind of give it a rest of
of formal space
we have kindergarten pre-kindergarten
groups still using that but there's no
lines right so they get gravit instead
of gravitating towards the lines they
can put their little goals out
everywhere it's still getting used but
it's not as a formal space
so we use that as a strategy
again the synthetics help us a lot the
other thing that we do is i we tell our
youth groups probably for the first two
weeks of the season
practices only sneakers no cleats
uh and they and they're they're great
with that they're pretty good with that
i had a conversation with a neighboring
town their turf manager the other day
and he said wow that's a great idea i
said all you can do is ask right you
know if they can they can say yes and if
50 of them do it that's great
um you know so you notice a difference
you notice a difference in the wear and
tear
if they're just wearing sneakers versus
even the youth wearing pleats 100
especially you know we're still not
growing right we're still the soil
temperatures like you said are still
still bouncing all over the place we've
had three days of rain
um
yeah are you covering are you able to do
any accelerating do you do
does that make any sense
we've we've talked about it for years
i've considered doing covers it's really
it's a labor thing for me more than
anything else of when the when to pull
those covers uh you know early or too
late right
um
we've thought about it for a long time
i'm almost ready to pull the trigger uh
especially just gold mouth repair right
in gold mouth recovery um where we can
do maybe 10 by 10 10 by 20
covers
but uh yeah it's
we see a difference and i have a turf
type tall fescue predominantly field
and it takes a long time to green up a
long time to green up yeah
and so that makes it less useful for you
uh in the spring
we use it no matter what unfortunately
it's one of those things it's a youth
lacrosse field we do javelin and discus
from the high school on that so that has
some interesting uh
um uh grenade launch uh type
uh impacts on it so yeah but we do what
we kind of do yeah so so let me ask to
carl's
opening stat uh when do you decide
you're gonna go with dick cut sod in
your gold mouths when is it like you
know what it's so wet i'll be honest
here we've we've never done any sodding
here in six years
um yeah we haven't you know i'm i'm just
big on pushing seed right see cleat
seeding in is it works it is it works
100 works yeah 100 works yeah but but
it's going to cost three times as much
what do you see as you're looking
forward for a heavy seed guy
are going to be your challenges
communicating that as a budget item
about to maybe double or triple
yeah finding seeds gonna definitely
gonna be difficult um we pre-ordered a
lot of seed this year which we normally
don't do
yeah i normally buy a lot of seed march
one we ordered a lot of seed in november
um you know we were lucky on pricing to
a point
um but yeah it's it's certainly going to
be an increased cost
it is interesting
a lot of places
we heard this from vicki wallace you
know the great vicki wallace in
connecticut joins us for a conference
call on thursday mornings and and she
was talking about
much of our industry as a buy you know
who's buying seed in the spring industry
instead of buying it in the fall uh
industry when you're buying your
fertilizer and a lot of guys are buying
fertilizer pesticides and the early
order programs uh at the end of the year
seed doesn't usually get bought until
now so you're already taking advantage
of buying ahead uh in
yeah i get great vendors right and they
and they kind of predicted this was this
was coming down the line back in in in
october or so
especially from the seed side right we
knew there was going to be a supply
issue uh and that increased cost all
right so so let's talk numbers here for
a second because i i don't think a lot
of people listen in or
because you know you probably are old
enough that most people said oh i core
and i see it in august you know or i do
it once a year uh and you know i
remember that from 25 26 years ago when
i started the repetitive overseeding
work right just throw it in they'll
figure it out put a lot it'll it's cheap
they can they can waste it it'll fill in
and so how much seed let's talk about a
typical
uh soccer field uh over the course of a
year uh how much seed will you be
throwing on that field and how what one
do you use what's the typical profile of
the fields blah blah blah yeah so uh we
have
mostly native soil fields uh we do have
some fields that have some heavy sand
top dressing sand slit drainage systems
so we would stand top dressing over and
keep them up and and flowing uh we use
definitely more seed in in those fields
just just because of the soil profile
um you know we're going out on almost a
10-day basis and putting seed down in
the gold mouth areas in the high wear
areas you're not talking a lot of seed
right uh you know a half a 50 pound bag
can go a long way right uh i'm from the
dave minner era right more seed is
better
it's better more seed is better um
so you know we're probably putting and
and from a timing perspective we're
doing more rye grass now right we're
doing rye grass probably until soil
temperatures
are are high enough um i normally do
about an 80 ryegrass 20 bluegrass blend
now
and then i switch at 180 as we get into
warm soil temperatures high higher
bluegrass
but you won't but you won't repetitively
overseed the bluegrass will you you'll
just do that more when it feels arrested
just the wear areas the weirdest
yeah the blue grass um and then some of
our high use fields
i have the budget were able to slice
seed in in in late august early
september um you know good good
cultivars right really good cultivars
um and and push that seed in and again
you're not talking a lot of seed um the
one we go one and a half pounds per
thousand two directions three pounds
total okay
all right good all right so listen
thanks for bringing up the soil stuff
that's the natural progression here of
what guys are thinking about in the
spring so um
well okay let's take the sand fields out
for a second let's just talk about your
native soil fields because that's what a
lot of people have so we'll start there
um what are your typical your put to bed
uh
soil management tactics and wake up soil
management tactics if you have any yeah
sure so you know we're doing a core
aeration in the late fall dragon cores
um
you know we'll overseed some of the
weary areas if we can
um you know it all depends on when we
kind of get snowfall here cold
temperatures you know we
sometimes we can do it sometimes we
can't as far as the seeding uh we'll do
a deep tiny aeration late in the fall
everything yeah all your native soil
fields yep everything everything
you know i want to keep those holes open
through the winter right soil movement
fracturing a soil freeze thaw
um
and then we'll and then we'll do a late
season nitrogen application
um
you know pretty pretty typical yeah
and that's it they're in bed and what
about waking them up nothing
waking them up um you know
you probably saw on twitter we end up
doing a lot of dethatching uh trying to
get that dead material out thatch the
goose poop
um you know all that kind of stuff out
of there um
kind of i think it helps the moisture
kind of get through that soil profile
through the thatch layer into the soil
profile waking it up
and we don't do any fertilizer
applications my first application is
going to be here in late april
um you know so you know that late season
nitrogen app is getting us through
those first couple weeks
good okay so that's a good point because
you know now you know you're throwing
seed you're opening up the soil you're
getting it going uh not a lot of
fertilizer what about mowing heights on
these native soil fields what are you
typically expected to
uh deliver to the people who use it from
varsity to youth so um i'm from the
school of leave it alone one one height
all year round
uh so i do two we do two and a quarter
that's it doesn't matter if it's 100
degrees out doesn't matter if it's 50
two and a quarter that's what it is um
i'm fortunate no one's ever complained
about uh how to cut here uh in other
facilities that i worked that i had
those conversations a lot but uh yeah um
two and a quarter that's it do you roll
the grass fields lightly in the spring
as part of your wake em up program
uh no we don't have a roller but our um
our mowing our mower that we use it's
fairly heavy machine it's got rollers so
we can stripe so it does have a little
bit of a rolling effect
and we'll probably go we're thinking
about if everything dries up today which
sun's starting to come out here a little
bit
we might put our first cut on monday or
tuesday next week kind of kind of get
the the fuzz off if you will are they
chomping at the bit ready to use them oh
they're they've been out already
all right let's be the baseball we need
a baseball game early in the week so
yeah okay
all right so let's talk about the sand
fields right um
uh let's start with some simple stuff
did you do this sand introduction and
are you glad you did uh it was right
before my time we had two
uh native soil fields heavy heavy soils
did not drain uh original construction
they were not graded correctly right
they were basically flat all right so
we're trying to get water movement off
those off those facilities so that we
had sand sand slit drainage introduced
one fields uh full-size soccer lacrosse
the other is my my soccer complex
the soccer complex is a more herringbone
drainage system with sand drains
and the biggest complaint when i started
here is we can see the sand lines we can
see the drain lines
well what are we doing for fertility and
they said well we don't know
well okay
you know
so you know we started with just basics
right basic fertility um and you know
from those fields now when we're coring
them we're coring them we're sweeping
cores we're adding two mil sand uh and
proper fertility is a
little different there
um they're not hugely sand based so
they're more of a still of a native soil
um so fertility wise is really not a
whole lot different do you like them i
mean do you like them would you consider
to do this to more fields because they
give you more possibilities in more
range of bad weather conditions yes yeah
i would yeah we've we have it on our
long-range plan to do some more fields
um with that it just to me it's just
it's
does the usage match the cost and we
have some some fields that don't get a
huge amount of usage i'd love to do it
but from a cost perspective once we
start starting doing it you know we got
it we got a core we got a sweep we got a
cn top dress
it's forever right it's a whole nother
thing right it's it's it's one more
thing on the 51 acres that you got to
manage but let me ask about something
that i'm sure you see come up i know
it's a big part of all the professional
sports turf managers is and how do you
approach a safety testing program how do
you look people in the face that are
using your fields and give them some
sense of you know the assumption is like
like it is with a lot of things like
people say this about chemicals well the
epa says it's safe so i can use it uh
they look at a field you and i look at a
field we might say
i don't know
oh well we're here they don't even think
about safety how do you approach that
conversation
in your role
with servicing so many masters yeah so
when i started here that was the first
thing it was like you're walking around
and we're we we did assessments right
and we we used uh uconn has a field
assessment guide and we use that and
said all right let's put a number to
these fields and where do they where do
we want to be
you know from a from a field safety
perspective on a natural grass
um you know we're filling in divots when
we can
making sure fields are as smooth as
playable as possible you know we
irrigation start we're making sure
irrigation heads aren't too high aren't
too low anything like that so we have
the ability to to maintain those you
know pretty quickly if there's an issue
um from a synthetic perspective we test
probably on a bi-annual basis to an
annual basis depending on what's going
on we have data independent data from uh
independent
uh lab we do gmax we do a hick test uh
we do infield depth um
it's it's an investment right it's a
huge investment for the community yeah
i'm so listen i gotta end with where we
started the conversation
you are again involved in this sports
turf manager a leader in in that
organization
part of your thing is to be an
ambassador to people who sometimes don't
even know they need a person like you
now of course you got to have the
resources like a town of weston can have
for sure
but there's also ways to at least have
an operation
that can make the most out of whatever
resources and talent you have and i
think that's the key
we need to keep exploring that there are
a lot of if you have a decent well-run
operation
there's a lot of well-intentioned people
without turf degrees that can probably
do this pretty well if they avail
themselves of nestma stuff if they want
to learn and talk to guys like you and
listen to these stupid programs that
carl and i spend our lives doing there's
ways of learning and doing this but i
fear sometimes there's no sense of what
is needed from an operational
perspective because like oh they just
cut the grass oh they just put they cut
and line the field and even if the guy
knows what he's doing there's not enough
time
to get the other stuff that you're we're
talking about here what are those
conversations like when you're having
them with people who don't even know
they need somebody like you
yeah it's you know a lot of stuff we've
never thought of that we've never
uh we didn't know it exists right
there's resources available from sfma
from nesma oh we didn't know this this
information is here and and we we have
this again now information age with the
internet and youtube i mean their stuff
everywhere it's available right
um so yeah just telling them what's
what's available i had a i did a
presentation a couple weeks ago for
parks and recs group and it's all
recreation park people and they said
yeah it's it's the conversation
communication with our manager with our
maintenance staff
for the you know users maintenance staff
and programmers right and that's a big
thing uh that we talked about
um and just
you know we have an aerator well we've
never used it use it right just use it
we have the equipment i got a barn full
of equipment i wish i had more guys to
use all the equipment we use what we
have available
we end up doing a lot of the agronomic
stuff we end up
sourcing it out because we just again we
don't have the time right we don't have
the time well and and speaking of time
yeah and speaking of time carl this is a
good time to bring that back in can you
imagine the wrench time
ben how much do you have to drive from
place to place before you can actually
do something you know what i mean
yeah we're just having a set up at every
field operation yeah we have a small
town fortunately but you know we have
guys and they just
they go out they have everything they
need they go and uh and service the the
campuses and whether it's the recreation
facilities that we have around town um
yeah it's a scheduling i spent a lot of
time sitting the seat scheduling right
and figure out
uh what's the best time and and you know
we have school vacation week in a week
and a half
it's a huge busy week for us
because there's no one here for a week
and we're doing everything under the sun
you know in a week when they get out of
here exactly yeah
as soon as school ends in june starts
all over again
all right carl what about questions for
ben before we thank them
um i i just got one question ben and you
alluded to it you've got um you've got
youth athletes and you've got all the
way up to varsity we've kind of noticed
it at cornell even with some men's and
women's teams the difference in
uh the effect you see on the turf the
traffic do you notice that at those
younger levels and is that something you
strategically move around if you if
you've got fields that maybe can take
the youth youth traffic but not the you
know women's varsity lacrosse yeah we
have the ability to slide fields a
little bit when we set things up so we
can move fields 10 feet 15 feet right
makes a difference from from gold mouth
perspective
um yeah i can tell you if the field's
been played on or not and and kind of on
the the size of an athlete for the most
part
um
yeah you know there's a pack of 30
kindergarteners running yeah they're
still going to do damage right they
still are
but yeah female athletes are lighter on
their feet not as much damage from them
but uh yeah you can certainly tell
who's playing there who's not um
yeah
ben thanks so much for taking any time i
really appreciate you joining us and
you're you're usually with us so it's
great that we get a chance to bring it
down i never miss it i try not to at
least
that's a lot that's it thank you guys
yeah we'll see all the next week
episodes 9 and 10 of the turf show but
for now take care enjoy some sunlight
while you can up here in the northeast
see ya
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu